podéis ver a mi espalda la gran fila que
tenemos en este momento en el centro de
Río de Janeiro hoy los brasileños 156
millones de lectores tienen que escoger
al nuevo presidente y también a 12
gobernadores de los 27 hasta Los
federados recordamos que la primera
vuelta a los otros fueron gobernadores
fueron Escogidos elegidos en la primera
vuelta
todos los sondeos dan como ganador a
Lula con el 54% de la intención de Voto
el último sondeo que fue publicado ayer
y 46% a bolsonaro son elecciones las más
reñidas desde el final de La dictadura
en
1985 y precisamente Hoy por la noche
conoceremos los resultados gracias al
sistema de voto de la urna electrónica
que ha sido a lo largo de los últimos
meses atacada por bolsonaro que ha
intentado
legitimizar el sistema de Voto
electrónico sin embargo en el último
debate ha reconocido que va a reconocer
el resultado pase lo que pase Y cómo se
vive la situación justamente en este
momento en Río de Janeiro
en Río de Janeiro las cosas de momentos
están muy tranquilas donde hubo
problemas en el último Ahora fue anoche
en San Pablo donde una diputada Carlos
sambel y muy bolsonarista impugnó una
arma contra militante del partido de los
trabajadores de Lula dijo que había sido
amenazada ha sido un incidente muy grave
si tenemos en cuenta que ante la
gravedad de estas elecciones
especialmente tensas el Tribunal
Superior electoral ha prohibido el
transporte de armas en las 24 horas
antes y después de las elecciones y no
es el único episodio Roberto Jefferson
un amigo personal y Aliado de bolsonaro
que estaba en arrestos domiciliarios
disparó con armas pesadas con fósiles
contra la policía que le iba a arrestar
por haber interrumpido violado su cárcel
domiciliaria y haber ofendido muy
seriamente una jueza del tribunal
supremo el propio bolsonaro el 11 de
octubre pidió a sus seguidores que se
queden en los Colegios electorales hasta
el fin de la curación de los votos para
que no haya fraude Así que a pesar de
sus declaraciones en el último debate
ese temen
disturbios en el caso de derrota de
bolsonaro Valeria Pues a usted muchas
gracias estamos muy pendientes Para
volver a conectar con usted más adelante
Ahora nos desplazamos hasta Sao Paulo
donde se encuentra Ángela Gómez Ángela
usted está en estos momentos A las
afueras de la ciudad en la localidad de
San Bernardo del campo Cómo llegan los
candidatos a esta elección
muy bien Valentina fuese Buen día para
ustedes y también para nuestros
efectivamente yo estoy afuera de la
escuela de esta ciudad de firmino correa
Precisamente en San Bernardo de Ocampo
aquí es donde se espera que en pocos
minutos llegue Lula da Silva para emitir
su voto y posteriormente dará algunas
declaraciones a la prensa antes de irse
para su hotel en la vía paulista a
esperar a que empiecen a salir los
resultados y bien sobre cómo llegan Pues
la verdad es que Lula da Silva según los
sondeos si llega a fortalecido
Precisamente en la víspera o datafolia
publicó su última pesquisa en la que da
un 52% de apoyo saludla versus un 48% de
apoyos a bolsonaro sin embargo y hay que
tener esto muy en cuenta las encuestas
ya se equivocaron en primera vuelta y
esto dio una gran ventaja Yair bolsonaro
que quedó fortalecido en primera vuelta
pero lo que sí nos muestra en este está
Clara tendencia de unas elecciones
sumamente apretadas y sumamente tensas
Ahora aunque Lula llega a fortalecido
pues lo que se espera es que bolsonaro
pueda hacer uso o aprovechar Estos
factores de último minuto como los
electores que no dan la respuesta real
en las encuestas o mucho más importante
estos indecisos que al final son los que
van a tomar la decisión de quién será el
nuevo presidente de Brasil lo que dicen
las cifras oficiales Es que 94% de los
electores eh Ya tienen claro Cuál va a
ser su voto Y pues lo que veremos
también es que bolsonar o de momento
lidera en Río de Janeiro y también en
Sao Paulo donde nosotros nos encontramos
pero ojo aquí al dato porque Lula da
Silva es quien lidera en Minas gerais se
Pese a que fue un estado muy visitado
por bolsonaro y la razón es precisamente
que aquí la creencia ganan
la presidencia